et on commence est matinal donc avec les
tensions à la frontière entre la Pologne
et la Biélorussie ou des milliers de
migrants son métier depuis plusieurs
jours après avoir tenté de rentrer en
Pologne des centaines de me
retrouver tout de suite c'est pour plus
de précisions notre correspondant à
Antoine Cléro à la frontière justement
entre la Pologne et la Biélorussie
[Musique]
Antoine clairon qu'on va retrouver un
petit peu plus tard en tout cas mais
regardez les réactions à 13 ans qui est
sur place Antoine donc vous êtes sur
place c'est quelle est la situation ce
matin
oui ben c'est le deuxième réveil ici sur
ce campement de fortune comme vous
pouvez voir derrière moi détente mais
aussi des gens qui dorment à même le sol
à quelques mètres seulement de clôture
de fil de fer barbelé la situation est
toujours la situation au niveau de
l'hygiène il n'y a pas pas de point
d'eau pas de toilette malgré tout une
distribution de nourriture et d'eau hier
dans la soirée est dans la nuit les
autorités les forces militaires
biélorusse sont installés une citerne
afin que les gens puissent avoir accès à
un peu d'eau et voilà c'est tout ce
qu'on peut dire au niveau de la
situation sécuritaire encore beaucoup de
monde ici sachez que dans la nuit ma
formation à prendre avec des pincettes
une information confirmer par les
autorités de Loris mais pas du côté
polonais 4 personnes aurait tenté de
franchir la frontière dans la nuit elle
aurait été repoussé également blessé par
parcelle clôture de fil de fer barbelé
extrêmement coupante donc des 4
personnes qui ont donc été blessé et
prise en charge par par les autorités
biélorusse donc repoussé
par par le la partie polonaise
j'aimerais également revenir sur les
tactiques de la Pologne pour dissuader
les gens de franchir cette frontière
hier on a entendu tout au long de la
matinée un message à répéter en boucle
par les haut-parleurs un message qui
disait la frontière est fermé le seul
passage vers la Pologne est vert vert
les points de passages officiel tenu par
les autorités polonaise
des textos envoyés alors mais moi j'ai
reçu sur mon téléphone un texto des
autorités polonaise qui disait
retourner à Minsk les autorités Bélarus
vous manque donc voilà ce qu'on peut
dire des tactiques polonaise pour tenter
de se centaines des milliers de gens qui
sont toujours très déterminé à passer du
côté de Polonais de la frontière a gagné
ainsi l'Union européenne merci beaucoup
Antoine pour toutes ces précisions vous
suivez pour nous justement ces tensions
entre la Pologne et la Biélorussie à la
frontière
Antoine